good morning John last week I discussed
with you the tiniest little door Bullis
little tiny animals I did this thinking
that it was a good use of of my time and
of your time and of the world's times
it's come to realize that I in fact was
contributing to what may be the single
greatest crisis that humanity faces
today overwhelming overpowering
dangerous amount of cute tiny animals
were a gateway for me then then it was
cats and cups then it was hedgehogs
taking bath before I knew it there was a
Loris holding an umbrella and John by
the end of it
Scottish folds just Scottish folds all
the time I used to think it was harmless
too but now I live in terror of the
Kotaku lives never before in history has
humanity been exposed to so much cute we
have no idea what this level of cuteness
is doing to our brains to our society to
our children who this is literally a
drug the endorphins released in your
brain upon seeing a cat snuggling with
another cat are similar to opium and the
more we see these images the more
desensitized to the movie becoming at
the same time our desire to experience
more cuteness increases so we search we
search until we find cuter and cuter and
cuter and cuter and killed earthing the
cycle must be broken of course many
people will say that cuteness is natural
and that's we have nothing to worry
about and that is true cuteness has its
place it helps us love our children and
our pets so that we don't neglect or eat
them and think about this just for one
moment what happens when I realize that
my cat will never be as cute as Maru I
still love her what about your child
your tongue can never be as cute as
Internet babies what will happen to your
love for him after you've been exposed
to so many Giga odds of adorableness I
don't know no one knows we've been
surrounded by this haze of cuteness for
so long that we've forgotten to be
afraid about our future some people are
saying the society is on the brink of
disaster that we will neglect our
children our responsibilities and all
day we'll just be cute cute cute cute
cute cute cute I would like to
personally call on Congress now to make
sure that the Internet is properly
regulated and that cuteness is curtailed
a certified Board of cute ologists must
be employed to create a rating system
for the amount of cute and television
shows
movies videos and pictures no Americans
should be allowed to adjust more than
their weekly quota there will be a cute
accent post on people who do ingest more
than their weekly quota people who
follow emergency puppy on Twitter
subscribe to reddit.com slash are slash
oh of course for people who search for
otter on Pinterest the cute tax will not
only help balance our national psyche it
will also help balance our budget this
will be a simple system to set up and
implement overseen by a new cuteness
song I would like to personally nominate
Jack Donaghy for that position I hear
he's been interested in getting into
politics he will ensure that we will not
limit people's experience on the
internet only that we and our children
will not be exposed to unsafe levels of
cuteness people have to understand that
this is being done for their good and
for the good of our country Jon I will
see you on Tuesday
[Music]